so your brother did i
was he is he a very business minded guy
too is he yeah and and he investor
entrepreneur himself totally and he uh
he went to dartmouth on on like a
football
recruiting invitation uh ivs don't give
scholarships so um we ended up my dad
ended up really grinding and my mom to
help him get in there and through it but
he's built some um relationships that
have gone above and beyond in in way of
what we've been able to create today but
out of school
he was invited to one nfl camp and he
was with the arizona cardinals and then
they passed
um and so he was just like all right
back to that enterprise commercial i'm
going from
division one double-a football to
got a job in real estate and then left
that and started an entrepreneurial
career
is he older or younger he's older he's
two years older but by the time we
started building the pll together which
was in 2017 you know he had booked 10
years of entrepreneurial experience wow
yeah so it was super helpful i could
bring
you know subject matter experience and
expertise in lacrosse and media
marketing savvy and then he was building
the bones of the business and
fundraising and such
wow
um
do you think that you'd be where you are
without him
i wouldn't have found it in someone else
or would it have taken longer i mean
it's a great question i don't think i'd
be playing
professional lacrosse without him i mean
him and i
were basically attached at the hip when
we were younger and fought all the time
we had to put a rule together
by the time we were
in our teens that we had to be on the
same team
and like neighborhood ball oh because
otherwise yeah we were flashed all the
time yeah i mean all the time even over
stupid [ __ ] like are you guys the same
size are you bigger than him he's
i'm a little bit taller than him now um
but he was always bigger than me and he
was a d tackle at dartmouth and the
captain of the football team and he was
300 pounds okay so he was a it was a big
dude and now you know he's caught all
the weight since
um leaving football but yeah i mean he
could throw me across the room pretty
easily
um and so we had that rule and then even
today like when we
ever get into like some type of
exhibition
um we'll play on the same team
but so sport was a was a connective
tissue for us and
uh to answer your question on the pll
wouldn't have done it i don't think
another business partner would have
worked either
because it was so hard
especially in the first year and a half
because we basically took over
the existing league at the time the
league that was paying me 6 500 as a
rookie to play
uh and we took most of the top players
in that league in year one
to come join us and there was just mud
slinging like behind the scenes between
their ownership groups
and and mike and i and so we got in we
had like many of many of late nights
um
stressed
uh finger-pointing
you know i was still
you know really focused on playing at
the highest level and he needed me to
and the league needed me to and so there
was always this
dynamic of me training for three hours a
day and
him being like when the [ __ ] are you
coming back to the office like i need
your eyes and ears on this and uh and
it's always been disproportionate up to
that degree because i still play and he
right boulder's a lot of the business
where do you guys um where's the sort of
delegation of
work what are you what is what are you a
little better at or have a better eye
for him what is he a little better at
yeah that's also how our relationship
has evolved as uh more mature people i
would say from when we were in our teens
fighting all the time natural
yeah
but you know he's he's really egoless
and we also appreciate each other's
skill sets and are
uh are always complementing each other
it's like a romantic relationship or any
type of partnership that you're in and
there's a reason why in a lot of
business schools they bring in
relationship therapists to teach a
course that's often mandated whether
it's at gsb or harvard business school
is your business partner is yeah it's
your second wife or second husband and
um
and
so you have to be thoughtful you have to
check in you have to be complimentary
you can't take advantage of that person
super open and honest
and that's gotten to us a place where
you know i feel this almost daily i get
to take part in the sexy side of the
business like i oversee our media and
content strategy and marketing
um and you know kind of
we call it our ops but basically the
product on field and mike does
everything from fundraising to
management of our entire org chart to
um you know kind of overseeing legal in
hr
um and like general business
but is that what he's better at because
i think i found this but i've found this
with
um
you know in my own life where i look at
some jobs that people are doing and i'm
thinking that must not be that fun they
freaking love it like there are certain
aspects of life thank god everybody's
different because there's somebody that
loves the details somebody that loves
being on camera somebody you know so
just because
what he's doing is not what would be fun
for you doesn't mean that that's not fun
for him and that's where like everyone
has their role and so that's where i'm
kind of curious how where you're your
main role with pll
and
your own brand like yeah
i mean that's and that's what's made it
so great is it just really fit nicely
right he
he runs the business i
basically
think through and execute the strategy
and the media and the distribution of it
and that's what you need in sports i
mean
we're a a
inside outside business not every take
some of the most valuable companies in
the world the most valuable companies in
the world
are are technology companies and they're
sas businesses so they sell software as
a service
and you basically have this product as
an entrepreneur that you build and you
test with your engineers and you hope to
achieve what they call product market
fit
where there's enough consumers out there
that like your product and then you
raise money to hire to basically build a
huge sales organization so you can grow
revenue and then you sell your business
and it's pretty linear and you don't
have to deal with this like pr and like
the whether or not people know the
founders or they're
consuming the product and judging it
sports entertainment entertainment is
hollywood and music
really
are so public facing and the ability to
constantly gather attention but
galvanize the attention of your consumer
drives the value of your company
and that is what lacrosse has never done
in its professional existence it's what
the nfl the nba
the nhl indycar nascar all these
properties have grown to become
successful at but then there's the whole
side of the company that's behind the
scenes
and that's making sure that the business
has profitability or at least a path to
profitability and is managing
shareholders and
is you know communicating with the
players and all this other stuff that
uh is so heavy and so dense and that's
what he leads
and he's built for it because he's
really really talented at it and he's
sharp around seeing the forest with the
trees
one of the things that is interesting
and different about
pll is that the players have equity is
that right they their equity their
shareholders in the company whose idea
was that and how is that working i mean
i know it's early on and that the league
started and officially under you
in 2019 right summer of 19. yep
but how is that working yeah i mean and
whose idea was that you know and why
like why would you not want to just own
the whole thing yeah well
so it's a good question why because when
we
when we went about building the pll we
saw the opportunity in our industry
which was lacrosse
and sports business and sports media we
could have just built another
mousetrap another version of what's out
there for team sports leagues they're
called trade associations
and found ownership groups and launch
teams and markets and probably would
have been okay
but we were also at this moment in time
and this is like
ten and a half years into the social
media era where the power dynamic has
shifted from teams and owners to players
and entertainers and
you've seen that come about through
athletes investing athletes taking
equity in brand partnerships and
athletes owning teams and
realizing that it doesn't have to be a
fleeting career which is where sports
has had all the leverage over us for so
long is the average expectancy of most
athletes is two to four years totally
and so what we were like is hey if we if
we are
innovators like we say we are and if we
want to disrupt sports let's do more
than just start a new league let's
change the way that maybe professional
sports at the team level function
with talent and
so we're true single entity meaning that
the
the governing body of the pll so our
capitalization table
um has everything from owners to our pll
employees to our players on it and the
teams are are owned by that overarching
body at some point it may shift to
a trade association or what the mls has
had which are still single entity but
they have investor operators which are
essentially their owners
that then govern their teams
it can get a little bit complicated but
what we do with the equity is we
basically are for single entity much
like uh a technology startup in silicon
valley we'll just treat our players like
our employees and if they're coming in
early and putting on the sweat equity on
the field why not as part of their comp
package we give them
uh stock and so
mike built the mechanics of it but it
was i think it was both of our ideas to
to again to to take advantage of
starting a league
in 2019 and what might that look like
with the trend of what we're seeing in
sports